merci
[Musique]
sur une prise de sang pour séparer en deux
groupes ceux qui ont un parcours fœtal et
ceux dont on ne sait pas quel
est le parcours et puis maintenant on peut commencer à
se poser la question est-ce c'est c'est c'est c'est
ça  donc je pense que les années à venir
sont super excitantes parce que maintenant nous
aurons le bon
fond de données pour répondre
correctement aux questions qui ont à voir avec la
reproduction de la perte de grossesse mais aussi
avec la santé des femmes en général
[Musique]
ici, nous avons montré qu'il  peut être utilisé
jusqu'à la cinquième semaine de gestation
si la grossesse est perdue, nous pouvons acheter un
test sanguin sur la mère apprendre à connaître la
génétique de la fonctionnalité
[Musique]
ouais donc dans ce cas pour cette
perte de grossesse il y a  trisomie 21 et cela signifie
qu'il avait le fœtus a trois
chromosomes du nombre 21 et cela
a été causé euh a causé la grossesse perdue
[Musique]
que ce projet fait tout le chagrin
et toute la tristesse que chaque
perte de grossesse est
euh importante parce que pour chaque
perte de grossesse nous obtenons un peu, nous en saurons
plus et nous pouvons utiliser les pertes pour
autre chose, donc je pense que ce projet
me donne l'espoir que moins de femmes doivent
traverser ce que nous avons traversé à
l'étranger
[Musique]